that's why I understand how anybody
could do like like ketamine like people
that do like recreational ketamine ever
done it never done it either but it's
scary you go into that k hole I can talk
about it wouldn't sound good k ol
doesn't sound good that doesn't sound
good to me I don't want to do that it's
some sort of animal tranquilizer right
now something you know what is thank you
what is it if it wasn't called K hole if
it was called wonder lust if something
was called wanderlust I'd be like let me
try it
yeah but they call it a k-hole after
they've been in it yeah it sounds
horrible
it sounds like darkness I don't want to
go there never has a desire to do
something that was gonna put you in a
k-hole [ __ ] that like acid not into it I
did that acid podcast with Joey hmm I
didn't think I can go that was the only
guy not on acid but Ari was an acid Joey
Lee it's [ __ ] hysterical I wasn't I
was like ah you gotta change the name
you can't call I'm not gonna take
anything called acid that [ __ ] me up
that's hilarious anyway should have
called it something else they think just
call it QT love ya want some QT love
yeah yeah yeah I'll take some QT love
what's it gonna do just make you look
use the jelly would drop some as he
didn't give a [ __ ] man